[Music]
never
hopefully I'm coming
through thank you Miss Wicked Wolf hope
folks are doing
well uh Carolyn is um is doing a little
better she's not feeling up for um
Extended um time at the computer I.E
doing a mod during a stream so she won't
be joining us today but um she's doing
okay she's focusing on getting better
and that's what she should be doing
thank you for asking though thoughts on
Doctor Who drama tune in tomorrow I
already shot a video on it I will not be
bogging down today's stream in that
because I already expelled that nonsense
from my body in front of a camera and it
has been recorded it needs to be
edited yes absolutely love for Caroline
thank you goer that's really that's
really wonderful from you I'll be sure
to tell her
that uh but
yeah I'll have a video about the Doctor
Who drama out
tomorrow Food For Thought does the
existence of extra virgin olive oil
imply that there's an extra [__] olive
oil option I'm not sure it does it does
imply that there's gradations of uh
being a virgin though which I would like
some definitions on that
please do I like bacon I like it well
enough I'm not
um I'm not bowled over by it the way a
lot of people are I'm not obsessed with
it like it's nice it's good as an as an
addin to other stuff by itself honestly
it's a little
much do I believe in the Great
Pumpkin I don't like to share my beliefs
I find that to be highly personal I'm
going to keep that to myself thank you
kindly I watched The Twilight Zone
episode with Julie numar as the devil
today I don't think I've seen that
one i' I've been jumping all over
classic Twilight Zone don't think I've
gotten to that one yet bowling for bacon
no Bowling For
Soup I used to like that
[Music]
band because she's the girl all the bad
guys
want uh have you heard about the plan
but cancel dark 2 animated series from
the early
90s um I've heard of it
it's I mean
like I tend to not find a ton of like
it's it's rare that something that did
not happen really kind of sparks my
interest like as a fact toid oh okay
then my brain just kind of moves on um
I'm sure it's a lovely video though
Harbor Holmes um Harbo holes does good
stuff so I'm sure it's a good video but
no I haven't seen it favorite slasher
villain I'm really not too big on
slashers I mean I gu guess Ghost Face by
default but see here's the
thing if ghost face is your favorite
movie slasher do you have to specify
which
one or I suppose which two since most of
them are
pairs because otherwise you're just
basically saying this mask is my
favorite CU they're not all the same
people found a new voice actor for Mario
yep I heard about
that here we
go well there's the medieval definition
of Virgin was basically synonymous with
unmarried ah yes well then by that def
definition I have reacquired my
virginity in recent
years uh that is a topic I will not be
touching at all in any way shape or form
is Wicked Wolf not because I don't have
thoughts not because I don't have
opinions but because it is an atomic
bomb of a topic and I do not have the
spoons to process and verbalize nor do I
have I and even less do I have the
spoons to deal
with everything that would happen if I
were to publicly State my feelings I do
not have it in me to deal with that that
is an off limits topic please for the
sake of my sanity if nothing
else but I wonder how they determine if
olives are virgins and make them sign a
purity pledge signing a Pur played is
pretty much guarantee you won't be a
virgin within a few years check the
statistics on that
one does Bowling For Soup good grief so
many does this imply this it's the theme
of the evening
apparently um does Bowling For Soup
imply you are bowling for the reward of
soup or are bowling on the behalf of
soup I feel like you are stepping in to
bowl for soup because um uh soup is just
having a hard time right now and can't
quite can't quite get its head in the
game and and you're just going to be a
good friend of soup you're just gonna
you're G to step in and you're G to be
that good friend and be there and bowl
for
soup
uh let's see that joke I pointed out to
you that's ableist do you think Russell
D Davies is the kind of person who' not
get defensive if you pointed out a
problematic joke uh threw on his watch I
have no
idea I don't know the man like here's
the thing there are people who might who
might under other circumstances be
amenable to a suggestion but either who
it's coming from or how it's delivered
throws things off I don't like there are
definitely some people out there who do
not take criticism well like that I'll
definitely agree to but like even people
who um like do take criticism while it's
it it's hard to say like and especially
when it's
um like most likely fan critique and
something that came later I don't know I
yeah can I impersonate
Shrek I don't know haven't really
tried um sure my Scottish accent can't
be any worse
than um Mike Myers is is
is actually I don't know if that's a bad
Scottish accent I think it's a
stereotypical typical typical Scottish
accent I'm not sure it's bad might not
be I don't
know I am in no position to
judge
donkey that's all you're
getting which comic book character would
I want to voice
ooh hm
[Music]
that um that is a good
question trying to
think
um hold on something's beeping I'm
trying to figure out if it's something
outside or if it's something in my house
it has stopped so I'm going to assume it
was something
outside
um I my brain is stumbling on this one
but it's a good question and I I want to
have an answer
ah
um I don't
know I don't
know w-e West he'd be
fun
they said it was impossible but I did it
I completed all of classic who oh no
it's possible I don't know anyone who
said it is imp possible
but um it's a
lot worst ghost face was from the worst
entry long lost brother and Scream 3
daytime soap terrador I scream 3 was the
last one I saw it was okay it's
fine first one's real good
still have you ever heard of a TV show
called only murders in the building I
have and I have not watched it because
it's on Apple TV which I don't have and
will not pay for it
uh I still have soup in the fridge might
toast some bread and heat it up there
you go that that's being Sur supportive
of soup how was your Friday the 13th
this uh October anything unlucky or um
spoy Heaven uh no not really I didn't
really do much uh on
Friday should be told I had a very nice
relaxed day with one of my partners and
that was
lovely that was my Friday the 13th night
before that I went and saw Lena
mckennett in concert she's amazing still
her voice has barely changed in 30 years
it's
astounding what is my favorite
soup kind of mood dependent sometimes uh
clam chowder sometimes French
onion those usually be the top two
contenders I think I do like a good soup
in
general can I do a rod sirling
impression uh uh I feel I feel like I
would need I need to have something to
read because I don't think because i'
I'd have to try and think of the kind of
things he'd say and also capture the
voice I don't think I can do both at
once if I can even do one or the
other um hang on a
second
uh uh
uh it is the middle ground between light
and Shadow between science and
Superstition it lies between the pit of
Man's fears and the summit of his
knowledge this is the destination of
imagination it is an area which we call
the Twilight Zone that's not great that
wasn't great I'll let it go with that
though the part of the thing is he has
no upper lip I don't know if you ever
noticed
that um have have I ever been in an
escape room once as a uh team building
exercise back when I still had the day
job I'm Scottish and never thought Shrek
was supposed to be Scottish oh I guess
that answers that question then doesn't
[Laughter]
[Music]
it navy bean soup never had that
one has my roof been fixed yet I mean it
it wasn't broken it just needed to be
redone before it started breaking
um excuse me no they're not done yet
hopefully they'll be done this
week been a bit distant from the MCU
recently is lowkey season 2 worth the
watch I mean we're only two episodes in
but so far yeah so far it's pretty good
I'm enjoying it am I GNA play The Dark
Side the second Dark Side detective game
I actually already have most of it
anyways some of it I did on stream some
of it I didn't I'm not sure I'm going to
do a review of it because I don't think
I have anything to say that was that
different than my first video and it
would basically amount to so you
remember what I said about the first one
more of
that
so if you liked it the first time and
wanted more get it it's
good I like ghost face because there's
no Supernatural stuff just a bunch of
losers and Kens being Los losers and
carens with knives
yeah tomato so r i don't get like
speaking of someone who loves Tomatoes
like broadly speaking I'll just slice up
a tomato and and and eat it but like I
don't get tomato soup I don't get it
it's just like what is this this is
nothing this is warm ketchup what are we
doing this is broccoli cheese erasion
and I won't stand for it I never said no
other soups existed besides clam chowder
and french onion I just gave my
preferences
so I saw you and Jesse got to Checkmate
in the prisoner Peter wiard is my
favorite number two with the chess
metaphor I think that episode does the
master manipulator Trope well that was a
good
like that show was just good I not
looking forward to getting to the finale
and trying
to explain what the hell
happens in it
it's
um let me see here sorry give me a
second
[Music]
can you go back and respond to the
questions from me I missed actually
every content supporter only respond to
me so I have constant validation um so
if I recall your question was about do I
think uh Russell T Davies would um
accept criticism like if he was told
something in his script was able to like
he might I don't know though I don't
know the guy like even people who are
receptive to criticism it can still go
sour depending on who's providing it and
um what Manner is being provided in so I
don't know it's not a question I'm
really comfortable at answering because
it you're basically asking me to do a
personality assessment on someone I
don't know and I'm not comfortable with
that have I heard the new Doctor Who
theme 15th doctor seems I have because
the because talking about that is
considered promotional material as
opposed to like proper review of the
stuff itself with the strike still
unresolved I have no
opinion if soup is liquid doesn't that
imply that it is a drink and not a
food well
no because it is not only a liquid it is
a liquid consisting of solids whether be
in diced up pieces or Blended to mix in
it is not liquid
alone terl staler thank you very much
for the Super Chat I appreciate that oh
reminder you get a little heart for me
and it's what guarantees that I'll get
your question even though I try and keep
up with the chat regardless any plans
for Halloween my D and group is doing a
spoopy themed campaign
session uh that night took off from work
especially for it also hi hi to you too
um yeah I'm probably going to tail
behind my
kiddo as um as they do their trick-or
treat thing so with friends so I'll be
very Superfluous but that's what I'll be
doing have I ever been to a cat cafe
no I found Texas Chainsaw Massacre
boring AF am I the only one I don't know
because I've actually never seen any of
those not the originals not the remakes
not the sequels none of it like I know
about it but yeah know I don't have an
opinion I've never seen the
thing is quill and sword done no Miss
Wicked Wolf we we were gone for a little
bit because like there was one night
where some people were sick and then one
of the sessions was going to be on
Steph's birthday and you know we wanted
to let the guy have his birthday it'll
be back
uh it's probably going to be wrapping up
in the not so distant future at least
this campaign but no it's not
done I actually turned 13 when Friday
the 13th uh fell in my birth month
however my birthday is on the 6th so I
had week off of having a 13th birthday
on Friday the
13th that
it's happened to somebody I'm
sure I've not seen it yet but is the
Loki episode title breaking Brad a
reference to the show or the phrase
Breaking Bad it is it is a pun using the
name breaking bad but it is but what it
is more directly referencing is stuff
that goes on in the show it is both as
any good pun should
be anyone watching follow the House of
Usher oh is that now out I got to decide
if I'm going to get to that that or not
I don't ah it's too much
stuff good
grief do I like Fanta soda no I don't
like any
soda I I don't like
soda what about Stone Soup Oh see now
we're getting to Folklore that's a whole
different thing sorry I genuinely melt
that as a self uh deprecating joke I
didn't want actually want you to go back
I don't worry about it 255 wasn't a
problem no
sweat do I like slow 9s love bels no no
they're
boring like some of them if if they go
big enough like I don't mind my heart
will go on because it goes huge huge and
bombastic most of them don't have the
coones to do that they're just boring
and dull
there a lot of good music in the
90s ballads not so much I mean ballads
are are a tough thing to do well at the
best of
times which doctor do you enjoy
cosplaying the most honestly just the
cosplay probably the
13th now granted I'm slightly biased to
the fact that my suit for the 10th
doctor doesn't fit properly
anymore
um so I'm slightly biased in that those
are my two my two most accurate cosplays
are 10th doctor and 13th doctor and the
suit doesn't really fit for 13th Doctor
to be fair the jacket doesn't really fit
the suit doesn't really fit for 10th
doctor to be fair the jacket for 13th
doctor doesn't really fit anymore either
but it's left open so it's less
noticeable
Tara staler coming back with the with
the Deep philosophical questions if soup
isn't a drink because it has solids does
that mean Boba is
food
oo after this we'll tackle whether or
not a hot dog is a
sandwich uh arguably
yes
wait isn't the strike over the writer
strike is the actor strike is
not saw this channel where they review
sci-fi ships they interviewed a guy who
uh designed CG ships for Tre and he was
like it's 20 years ago I don't remember
why would you do that interview he
doesn't have anything else going
on I mean I I think that that honestly I
would kind of blame the podcasters to be
like did you do like a preliminary like
we'd like to talk about this in specific
do you have thoughts you want to share
and if he comes back going well I don't
really remember much book a different
guest Boba is a menace it's like
drinking something with tadpoles in
[Laughter]
it Gauntlet is
[Music]
thrown
who has the most obnoxious ads uh among
tnamed Chinese companies Tik Tock or
tenu if temu is what I think it is those
are more
annoying uh have you heard the eighth
dror big finish the natural history of
fear nope I haven't heard that
one uh binging follow the House of Usher
right now Flanigan's best work in my
humble opinion I might have to check it
out then now I haven't seen all of his
stuff actually the only one I've seen is
Haunting of blind manner which I liked a
lot I couldn't get through Haunting of
Hill House because it was childhood
trauma the show and I hit my limit and I
just haven't I just haven't checked out
his other stuff historical literary
figure that the doctor hasn't interacted
with you'd most like to see
none like I'm I find the historicals way
more interesting when he interacts with
an event or a time period than with
specific people I'm really sick of him
interacting with specific historical
figures
stop it's boring and it reinforces the
great people of History nonsense view
that we have of history in the first
place and it just it it changes it from
an exploration of a period of time into
Hey look it's whoever the
[__] stop it's boring and it's never
been
good the classic ER historicals are
better because he rarely ran into
anybody
famous modern ER modern era historicals
are mostly crap you know what yeah you
know what I'm drawing a line on this
stop with the historicals if you're
using it as a vehicle to meet a famous
person stop it they're all bad how bad
they are varies some are better than
others but they're not
good the best historicals do not feature
the historical
figures they
don't there you go there's your there's
your doctor who hot take for the
day how will you cosplay as the new
doctor given that he seems not to have a
permanent look I don't know uh partially
because
um I I can't afford to order anything
like that right now and I would say it
will probably depend on what I can can
get a hold
of because um you know going to places
that that stock this kind of stuff
they're going to stock one of a couple
uh you know maybe several different
looks of his and I'll just probably base
it more off what's available than
anything
else
uh regarding the side strike Studios
pulled some dirty Shenanigans then
layered on some victim blaming yeah it's
not going to work nobody's on their
freaking
side
we're going into our Jaffa Cakes
biscuits or cakes
territory going back about 15 minutes
within a fantasy context if you're
reincarnated resurrected and you
remember the previous life does that
count as resetting one's
virginity it depends on whether you
believe virginity to be um an act of the
Soul or of the body if you believe that
the engaging in the carnal Act is an
impact on your soul then no it doesn't
reset your virginity if you believe that
it is strictly an impact and an effect
on one's body then
yes saw the new trailer for Wonka I
haven't seen the latest one I don't
care I just don't
care what about moon pie neither Moon
nor
pie false advertising very disappointing
super Supremo Omega thank you very much
for the Super Chat on animation do you
blame sledit the success of Toy Story
for the decline of handdrawn 2D art in
the late 90s and 2000s or was it
something
else
um no I blame
Shrek because Toy
Story Pixar was a
fluke until somebody else also had
Success With
It
and once Shrek happened Shrek was the
movie that everyone went I bet you we
could make one of
those and Shrek messed things up in
other ways also leading to the
um uh the the stunt casting of Hollywood
people instead of just you know getting
voice actors
um 2D animation was kind of declining on
its own uh in the late 90s because they
were greenlighting bad
movies like that that was just part of
what was going on too so like 2D was
stumbling all on its own Toy Story comes
out 3D it's like oo but that's really
expensive and really hard not a lot of
companies can do it and then DreamWorks
did Shrek like they did ants before that
but it nobody remembered that one after
a few years but then Shrek was
huge and everyone was like oo we could
do that so I blame Shrek if we're going
to blame
anybody our philosophy is send a
question in chat it was full of
typos no worries I do that kind of
nonsense all the dang time let me see if
I can find
it um oh here we go an unearthly child
losing distribution rights am I okay
with RTD maybe remaking it the general
situation I'm going to have a video out
um hopefully tomorrow on it's shot I got
to edit it and get a thumbnail and all
that um the idea of RTD remaking
it no short answer no no I'm not I'm not
really okay with
that for the same reason I don't like
the the recasting of classic era um
doctors or companions uh anyways so like
it just it just feeds into something I'm
already uncomfortable with
so my my own take on that is no um I
think House of Usher might be worse than
Hill House on that front trigger
warnings for sure oh well then I might
not get very far into it so we'll see I
told you my hero Academia is trying to
do a Redemption Arc for a hero who was
abusive towards his family and obsessed
with
surpassing uh another rewatching the
show his interaction with his rival is
so pathetic the other great the other
hero greets him politely he reacts with
hostility the other guy is like bit rude
but whatever okay yeah I mean sounds
like this is just somebody with a lot of
issues um have I seen has been Hotel no
I've only just started watching um hell
of a boss so I don't have an opinion
formed on that yet either so don't don't
ask me
yet uh
isn't Rosa a good historical figure if
you're
asking if you're asking me if I think
that is a good episode not especially
no
no I I have a lot of issues with a lot
of the historicals and it's not always
the same issues every
time some of them have their own
slightly more unique issues I don't
really think Rosa is an especially good
episode I'm not gonna slam it because I
know it means a lot to a lot of people
and I'm not here to to you know shame
anybody for liking a thing but I don't
think it's especially good Rosa Parks
was an amazing
figure and for what doctor who does with
historical figures that was about as
good as it was going to be but that
that's grading on a scale that's grading
on a curve that I don't feel like
granting it
today the show as a whole I
mean uh really sad that Elliot is
leaving Tom Scot's channel
oh oh I missed that oh I hadn't
heard
huh for all the hard work on videos
lately thank you Hypno Amber that's
really nice Erica o coming in generous I
that is really appreciated genuinely hi
ver I just started watching Omens I've
seen your review excellent stuff thanks
for the tip I love the book and now the
show book's good too the it's funny
though cuz the bit that always stuck in
my head the most of the entire book kind
of got a
nod in the second season but it didn't
it didn't really properly
happen and that's
when people are sneaking into the I
think it's the missile
silo and it's it's noted that nobody in
there questions their presence because
all the security is designed to keep
people from being able to get in so the
assumption is if they see you just in
there you must be authorized to be here
you wouldn't be here
otherwise um and there's this comparison
made to bees at a beehive that bees will
will fight to the death to keep
something from getting into the Beehive
but if it gets in they leave it alone
because they assume it's supposed to be
there I don't know if that's actually
true of bees but I always did like that
that they sold green ketchup to promote
Shrek I remember when purple ketchup
thing was a thing for like a month it
was
gross because like they sold it as it
tastes just like ketchup but it's weird
colors like no the texture was all
wrong I want a historical where the
celebrity is uh Flatout antagonists stop
having the doctor gush about how
important they are to history I mean
like maybe that'd be a slight shake up
I'd rather they just leave them alone
just stop just
stop uh early thoughts on hell of a boss
it's
uh it's a
lot I've only seen the pilot so far so
like this very early
days are the 90s the worst time for slow
love bouts I think the 80s was way worse
I'm not going to get into a debate over
which was worse I'd say they were both
pretty damn bad I would say the '90s was
mostly bad because they didn't improve
on what the80s did it was the same kind
of nonsense would I ever write a
cookbook hell
no absolutely
not
H mustache fam love yall like chicken
okay thank oh thank you for stopping in
super
Desi okay so historical literary setting
uh you haven't seen yet you most want to
see the doctor engage with
um I would like to
see let's see
here
[Music]
i' I'd like to see him um engage with
the with the moris people like moris
Spain or like really engage with it not
just like have it be a side note in
something like it was in uh can you hear
me which is an episode I like but it
historical setting was pointless I got
to check the Discord I shall be right
back soon uh cuz reminder that's the
only other way to get uh questions
answered other than super chats is to
ask them in the Discord which is a
patreon exclusive
perk uh do or did you listen to much
radio drama if it's still a thing in the
US it still is in the UK it's not really
that much of a thing over here and no I
never really did listen to it uh if
dreams of fire that's my novel for
people who don't know were to be adapted
as a drama any medium and the writer was
not you who would your choice of
dramatist be oh
I have no
idea I don't know shoot for the stars
Neil Gaiman give me a call what attracts
you to the IDE idea of playing Puck so
much Puck is an archetype I enjoy a lot
Puck is a trickster Puck is Bugs Bunny
he's lowkey he is there for fun and
Mischief I just enjoy that and it's
really fun and whereas I would never get
to a chance to play lowkey I could play
Puck I could get that role for that
stage show and
oh and he's he's also got
um my favorite line in all of State all
of uh all of
Shakespeare so there's that that's
always to his
benefit uh
see let me pull the full thing up so
that because I sometimes I get
the uh I get the front part wrong there
we go shall we their fond pageanty Lord
what fools these mortals
be like true words never spoken what
fools these mortals be indeed
indeed uh the other day I rewatched Deep
Space 9 episode where O'Brien gets
arrested by some aliens and locked into
a mental uh simulation of jail for 20
years for 20 years subjective years that
are only actually a few hours the
episode is about him dealing with PTSD
from this orrian has a daughter who
going by the actress's age was six or
seven at the time he opts not to tell
her he's having trouble do you think
that's a right approach as a parent like
in the episode he gets annoyed with her
several times because she's pestering
him to play with her and he can't handle
it and she doesn't understand why if you
had a six or seveny old would you tell
them if you had PTSD like that is a
little elaborate for what if broadly
speaking broadly speaking I have been
open with my own child if some things
were difficult for me or if I was having
a bad day would I go into all the
intricacies of PTSD and why I had it uh
if I did no probably not not at that age
but it would kind of give some context
so it's not just
confusing you know kids can be
understanding of this is something
that's difficult for me could we do
something else or can you give me a
minute I finished that book about humans
having uh to move to the South Pole once
in the South Pole the humans created
arrays of ice adapted human animal
hybrids to serve them who rise up
against us so we have
to um so we let them out of the under
lab prism where they were created do you
think this Trope is overused in sci-fi
yes yes it it
is
especially with the whole like
artificially created element
because I feel like in many
ways that
Trope comes up as a way to kind
of
have slavery as a plotline without
acknowledging how real slavery
happens because when it's that are like
oh no robots ACH achieve sensient and
now we have to think of them as people
whoops we didn't mean to ins slave them
we just we didn't realize they were
autonomous it's like a whoopsy slavery
like if you're actually going to do a
story about slavery and about rebelling
From Slavery deal with the realities of
slavery somebody came and took your
rights away
and I feel like this sci-fi Trope is a
coward's way of doing it by trying to
make it more sci-fi-ish and being like
Oh but they created this thing and like
oh do they have the right to this like
these are these are questions that have
been explored and I don't think there's
much juice left in them to be completely
honest a while back I read a book uh
that was about a retired Roman soldier
joining a trading expedition to the
Baltic trade uh with the unknown tribes
there the leader of the Trey mission is
uh
Phoenician that I I I might be
pronouncing that rightly I might not be
uh SE Trader who cheats people several
times also frequently prioritizes profit
over not risking his Crews lives an an
ancient Phoenicia now mostly inside the
state of Israel their language was
related to Hebrew do you think that's
close enough to make it a depiction like
that anti-semitic I don't know I don't
know and I don't feel that's my call to
make what I will say
is even if it is it's probably going to
go over the head of most readers because
I don't unless it is pointed out in the
book itself most people don't know that
don't know that um that ancient culture
or location is now uh inside of the
state of Israel
like that's not common knowledge most
people are never going to know and never
going to make that connection does that
make make it not anti-semitic not
necessarily depends on the specifics but
again I do not feel qualified to make a
call on
that I saw your short on body swapping I
was actually thinking about this again
recently myself if you have a universe
where Souls don't exist and a body swap
is just copying person A's brain state
to person B and vice versa in this case
person a feels like the person B but
really they're still person a just with
person B's memories and neural pathways
like when the brain states are switched
back person a will feel like they have
the memories of being in person's B body
and then come back to their own body but
those are false memories or more
specifically their person B's memories
of being memor their person B's memories
when person B thought they were person a
the upshot of this is that it's never
person a doing anything in person B's
body but instead it's person B doing
things in person B's body with person
A's memories and neural
patterns I feel like you're splitting
hairs
like okay so Souls don't exist but like
functionally you're still taking the
Mind State and moving it from one to the
other and then back so I don't get how
you're coming to the conclusion you do I
feel like you're trying to legalize your
way out of the actual nature of a body
swap because if your conclusion is
correct well then for all intents and
purposes a body swap never actually
happened two people just had a
delusional state for a little
bit and then it's not a body swap
anymore then it's something else and I
don't know what to think of that that's
assuming I even understood the question
I might not have prisoner The Prisoner
favorite number two
I I go back and forth between
um the one
from a crap what is it
um I really like the one in Chimes of
Big
Ben and I really like the one
in ah what
is damn it what's the name of that
episode hang
on
checking uh
[Music]
um Dance of the Dead I like that one too
those are both really good doctor who do
you have any thoughts on Donna's
original departure or how RT RTD2 will
try to fix it her original departure was
beautifully tragic I don't know how
he'll try to fix it I think what the
thing is is it'll be very difficult for
him to do it in a way that doesn't feel
just hand wavy uh and if he does that
the immediate question question is going
to come up well why didn't you fix it
earlier so I mean like the actual answer
is he wasn't showrunning anymore mafa
didn't have any interest in dealing with
it it said like there are logistical
answers but what's the watsonian answer
for that and if it's not a handwave I'll
be curious to see what it
is I don't know what it'll
do I'm trying to get back into reading
sci-fi I had to recommend one
LGBT um one LGBT plus sci-fi novel what
would it be preferably on the gothic end
of things
I am not as well read as you might think
I am I do not have a suggestion off the
top my head for that um suggestions in
chat do you think the Timeless child
Cliff Hanger chimel left with the fob
watch will ever be addressed if not why
do you believe chimel left it in there
um no I don't or at least not for a very
long time because I have have a hard
time believing that too many creators
would want to touch that thing just
given how toxic the fan response was if
nothing else even if they thought they
had an idea of what to do with it why do
I believe he left it
in I
think I think he thought he was leaving
new strands for future right future
writers to pull um but he didn't he just
didn't finish his own story I think I
he continues to claim that he told the
story he wanted to tell and he finished
telling his story if that is true then
Chris chel and I have fundamental
different concepts of what telling a
story means of what it means to tell and
finish a story and we have
irreconcilable differences in how we
Define those
things um I've watched Flash Gordon for
the first time this weekend it occurred
to me how much the female lead is being
forced to marry the villain but is saved
at the last minute has become a cliche
since then why do you think that Trope
is so
overused I mean it's just a it's just a
variant of damsel and distress and
damsel and distress as a literary device
is old as storytelling
so it's overused because it's well
ingrained in a lot of culture do you
think Bill Mark claims to be why do you
think Bill Mark claims to be a Democrat
despite all of his conservative use cuz
he's a
fool he's a fool with no
um self-reflection that's why all right
I'm back in the main
chat
[Music]
um let's see okay we've got some new
super
chats let's see Lewis
Ward G to head out for the night have a
good one oh well thank you very much for
that I appreciate it uh our philosophy
is Will BBC pull unearthly child affect
other doctor who I don't know no I doubt
it um but we'll see I
actually without getting into the whole
freaking thing because
again video out tomorrow hopefully
but I I expect that this not carrying of
the
[Music]
um of
the um unearthly child on BBC I player
ultimately expect that to be
temporary um I think if they weren't
trying to get everything up there in
time for the 60th I think that this
holding would just delay until this got
sorted um I think the only reason
they're putting up without it is because
it's going to get a boost with the
upcoming 60th and they're gonna take the
hit have I been to many sci-fi
conventions I've been to a few Vermont
ComiCon used to have um like I'm G to
lump together uh comic conventions with
sci-fi I haven't
technically um the only Sci-Fi specific
ones I've been to are Gala Fray 1 which
I've been to twice I used to do the
Vermont ComiCon back when that was Sil a
thing it no longer is I've been to
terrificon which was quite fun and I've
been to Rose City ComicCon which was
also a lot of
fun my favorite number two is many happy
returns I do like that number two
but what I love about that episode isn't
the number two if that makes sense
uh let see the part that I missed about
Gooden's was the bit about how any
record LIF in a car long enough turned
into a copy of Queen's Greatest Hits
yeah I remember that bit too I feel like
season two kind of had a nod to that
with the um uh the is it Buddy Holly
Every day it's a getting closer like it
gave a justification for that but I that
felt like at least on its initial
premise kind of a nod to
that you didn't read that part but do
you agree it's obvious what's going to
happen in a Sci-Fi story if someone
makes a slave race well
yeah yeah first of all they're the bad
guys immediately and automatically
second of all the slave race will rise
up or if they don't that will be the
object lesson for some stupid
reason
I haven't been to a Sci-Fi con since
forever I haven't been uh to a Fur
Con uh at all yet I have not been to a
Furon I have
um furries that I know who have and
enjoyed it
greatly uh ever encountered Wellington
paranormal it's the same universe
as what we do in the shadows oh I got it
I've told people people before don't
don't don't do abbreviations don't do
that my brain doesn't work like that
lots of fun casually Progressive too um
I haven't encountered that um you're not
exactly selling it to me by telling me
it's the same universe as what we do in
the shadows CU I haven't watched that
and I'm not really compelled to
either oh boy you've got Hammer into
Anvil next well next to be released
we've already seen it and recorded the
um episode on it it's just not out
yet so you folks have hammerin Anvil
next
I have moved past
it Dharma reupping support remember 22
months my goodness happy anniversary ver
thank
you do I like raspberries it would be
very strange that I'm eating them if I
didn't even though I'm the most vanilla
siset person you'll ever meet the
othering and gaslighting I got as a kid
has drawn me to other people who have
been
othered I that's good because like the
thing is you don't have have to
be queer you know
trans by pan gay whatever to be able
to have
empathy
and be supportive of that Community or
maybe even find a place um within
aspects of
it do I plan to attend that GFR
one
words do you plan to attend galr 1 in
2024 yes indeed I
do
ah that reminds me hang on
sorry doing this thing where I need to
check something while I'm thinking of it
[Music]
um H okay cool all right that's
fine Supreme Omega back in with the
Super Chat thoughts on stepen Spielberg
do you feel he's unfairly typ cast as
the big familyfriendly director because
he can do stuff like minority port and M
and Munich um it is a little bit odd
that he's uh generally believed to be
some familyfriendly director given you
you
know like Indiana Jones especially those
early ones like they they went rough
sometimes you know so not even just the
stuff that that you mentioned I think
part of it is that a lot of the stuff he
produced and this would have been the
80s and the 90s were incredibly
familyfriendly because like he was a um
a producer and his name was attached to
stuff like Tiny Tunes and Animaniacs and
The Goonies and I
think in some ways that did more to
impact people's thoughts and image of
him more than his own actual directing
filmography did uh if that makes any
sense there are too many acronyms and
fandoms and government organizations
whatever internet shorthand is trending
these days TMA too many acronyms I had
oh God I I keep like whenever I look
into stuff that is related to what I do
for a living and it's like tips for this
or help with this or hey have you
considered this and they're using all
these freaking acronyms and I'm like I
have to look up what the hell that means
apparently everybody else who does what
I do as a living can like somehow hold
all this nonsense in their head I can't
so he directed Schindler's List he did
but like also first trassy Park was
PG13 people got eaten by dinosaurs on
screen so
huh hi ver by the way today October 17th
2023 is the canonical date of Tony Stark
using The Infinity Gauntlet to decimate
thanos's forces and Avengers endgame
which would also make it his death
day Fs in chat for Tony Stark
Schindler's List is is not
familyfriendly nor is Saving Private
Ryan for that matter do I car pumpkins
yep every
year sorry for the initials it's okay
seal I'm not mad at you like I I just I
have to remind
people not good for my brain Jaws was PG
this because PG-13 didn't exist back
then PG in the
70s could go quite
hard like 70s PG could be a hard PG-13
these
days I rewatched Raiders very recently I
don't know if I ever previously spotted
the to Benton character who's clearly
played by a white
guy there's some of that sprinkled
around Temple of Doom is still PG what's
because the MPAA doesn't go back and
rate them just because the rating system
changed Temple of Dune is one of the
reasons we have PG-13 as a
rating um
so you know it they're not going to go
back and redo it the other day I found
my brother's kid was sick when I was
really drunk I thought I'm not sure I'm
really worried she might die I only see
her every other week
then next day I worried properly but am
I bad for having a
thought for having that
thought um no like
we we've kind of talked about this
before 255 like you're not bad for your
thoughts for me from my perspective
I don't I'm not trying to get bogged
down into the weeds
of
um uh philosophy here but I'm a
consequentialist I'm not going to say
that what you think or what you believe
or what's in your heart doesn't matter
at all but it is vastly secondary to
what you
do so you're not a bad for my
perspective you're not a bad person for
your thoughts you're not a bad person
for your instincts you're not a bad
person if you have a nonideal gut
reaction to
something it's what you
do following that
thought that can be good or bad it's
what actions you take based on that
thought so
like this is something that that
freaking I can't think of a better
example but like white people give get
really hung up on you know oh my God I I
like turned around and and I saw this
this black man and I got I was very
scared all of a sudden but then I felt
so bad because that was a racist thought
I'm like you're not bad for a racist
thought if you had that thought
recognize it confront it try and do
better next time if you turn around and
went oh my God don't touch me you
horrible horrible black person then
you'd be a bad person because of the
actions you took as a result of that
thought
if you Ma an innocent man yes then
you're a bit of a bad person but you're
not bad for your
thoughts and I have to believe
that
because there
are there are people who live around me
that I
know don't think well of me but I don't
think they're bad people people as long
as they're not doing anything Wicked
with those thoughts you don't have to
like me you don't have to think I'm a
good person you don't have to think
lgbtqia plus people are
good just don't be an
[__] don't do [__] things don't
strip people's rights away you don't
have to like us your thoughts aren't the
problem your actions are the
problem was also the first time I
watched it since you did your favorite
film scores yeah you're completely right
about that part of the desert Chase
thank you Rowan thank you very
much once again ver Mr calling as a
therapist I don't have the spoons to be
anybody's therapist other than my
own and
occasionally do my best to help other
people with my untrained
ramblings these are my thoughts these
are my Notions ultimately I do not know
what I'm talking about
so I will give you my opinions and my
thoughts and they whatever I share will
be true of me at the time I say
it but I'm not a infinite font of
knowledge I finally have my bottom
surgery consult this week looks like
I'll be able to get it done in April yay
that's great Louise
congratulations
I actually get hung up on seeing a black
teenager who looked angry and getting
angry like
again and and getting scared again like
your thoughts aren't aren't the problem
it's what you do with
them so when you have a thought that
could lead to destructive
Behavior do your best to recognize that
and do not act destructively off that
thought
but the thought's just the
so
H I'm G to wrap it up there everybody
thank you very much for joining me
um how much is a commission review on
your patreon cost depends on what you're
commissioning
$60 gets you two episodes of a TV show
or a movie um if you want a book that's
100 um I'm might even have to raise that
up even higher because honestly I get so
bogged down by the book stuff um but
that's what it's at right now and um
although I might have turned that one
off temporarily until I'm caught up on
the books I actually can't remember if I
did that or not I know I thought about
it but anyways yeah $60 is the base
level if you want me to say like watch
an entire season of Television that's
going to run you quite a bit more
they're all in tear on the
patreon probably talked about this some
previous chat but I usually usually
don't manage to catch them so sorry if
you've already said this before did you
ever do a reaction to the
prince I did a review on the break room
of Geeks so if you go to the break room
of Geeks you'll find it
there okay I'm gonna wrap it up there
thank you everybody do I review video
games um if you're asking on
commission potentially
um message me about it and it depends on
the uh expected length of the video game
that's probably also going to run you
but if you want to commission me to
review a video game message me about it
and we'll talk but
unless it is a game that I can wrap up
in four hours or less I'm gonna say
that's it's got to be at the $100 tier
anyways ah thank you everybody for
joining me I hope you all have a great
rest of the week uh tomorrow I will
hopefully have a video out on the stuff
going on with Doctor Who and the um
rights conflicts with um an unearthly
child um and tomorrow I will also be on
Twitch again I'm going to try out cozy
Grove we'll see what I think of that and
um
Saturday um Saturday video might be up
in the air in terms of what I'm doing
but there'll be a video on Saturday so
yay have a good
night just remember that you are
beautiful you are valid and you are
loved you are the council and I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
adjourned
mcity